Allahbar Allahbar
Allahbar
Allah
[Silence]
A shed when
I There was
no
[Silence]
Are you in for now?
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
My dear brothers, respected elders,
beloved youth, mothers and sisters,
esteemed viewers and listeners, we thank
Allah subhana wa ta'ala for keeping us
alive one more day on the path of Islam
on the and allowing ing me and you to
enter his house and worship him in the
manner that pleases him. I ask Allahh to
accept from me and except from you the
little we do in his path. And I bear
witness there is no deity worthy of
worship except for Allah subhana tala
and prophet Muhammad sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam is his last his final messenger
for surely who Allah subhanaa tala
choose to guide Nelson can misguide and
whoever chooses to misguide Nelson can
guide him back to the path and we seek
refuge in Allah from darkness of
ourselves and evil of our deeds for
Allah is all knowing and allseeing what
his creation does
today's topic might be a little harsh
for most of us but it's a topic that I
pondered and thought about for over a
month, possibly two months, and thought
about how can we bring it all together
into perspective so we can
understand.
First and foremost,
I've been saying this for a long time
and I keep repeating it till I'm
probably boom in the face or I die, is
the fact that Muslims do not have
organizations today built up that can
sway our opinions.
You can look around and see in America
there are large think tanks who are
affiliated with thoughts and processes.
But Muslims around the world really
don't have a think tank. We have never
invested into or have seen the need to
have opinions that can be put forth.
And that is the case in US that's the
case in Europe, in UK, in France.
We live in these countries.
We pay taxes in these countries.
But we don't have any agency.
We show up
because we have to show up and we feel
showing up and that's it. My job is
done. Alhamdulillah. I'm done. But we're
not invested in these processes or
communities. We're just an idol
person who stands by and sees how
things
go downhill.
For example,
how many of you in this room in this
message today know what Project Blue is?
You see, I'm already seeing some blank
faces looking at me. What is that?
That is one of the largest proposed
data centers that is going to be put in
Tucson.
And not only that, it's going to draw
probably about four to 5 million gallons
over two years from ground aquafers to
cool the data center. Not only that, it
will elevate your electricity bills by
15 to 20%.
Yet again, we are a taxpayer in the city
of Tucson in the Puma County and we have
no care about it whatsoever.
We are idle bystanders
who just see things destruct and then we
complain. Why are we in the processes
that we are?
Why are Muslims being
tightened around the world? Why the
screw has been tightening on us?
Ask anybody today
who is the number one terror group.
Muslims.
Yet we are the most persecuted group in
the entire world
is because we don't have an agency. We
have no interest in the process.
We think and we feel if I paid my taxes
that's good enough.
How many of us have reached out to our
representatives, our congressmen? I can
guarantee you if you did it was because
the visa for your wife was stuck or your
visa for your brother-in-law or your
brother and sister was stuck. That's the
only time we reach out to congressman or
congresswoman. Can you write a letter
for our behalf to the immigration agency
so I can have the visa processing going
and that's something that is really bad
because this is something that we have
witnessed in the history and we have yet
ignored it over again. You see, Muslims
have ruled the Christian nation longer
than any Christian nation has ruled the
Muslim nation.
Muslims ruled Spain for about 950 years.
Let's say thousand years some.
They had the same Quran you and I have.
They were reading the same surah.
Oh, but you see the brothers understood
it this way. You see, Allah is talking
about that idiot Pharaoh. You see, that
was the fool who didn't listen to Allah,
not understanding the Quran that Allah
sent you is forever living. It's talking
to you.
It's telling you.
No, no, no, no, no, no brother. That's
not what Allah says. It's for the
Pharaoh. It's for the for the pharaohs
that came down because wasn't listening.
What happened
when the Spain falls? The most
humiliating defeat happens.
The last person who ruled Spain, if you
go to Spain today, there is a post there
memorializing where he stood on his
horse and cried. So his mom looked at
him and said, "You were not a man enough
to defend. Don't cry now. There was not
a single person left to make the forum.
We're talking about a nation that was
ruled for a thousand years.
8,000 years.
We're not talking about 5 months or a
year or four years or 5 years or 20
years. We're talking about thousand
years.
That's centuries. That's 10 centuries.
You see what Allah is talking to us in
the Quran we're ignoring it
the whole time
Allah wasallam mentioned in a hadith
after jihad
what is jihad
he said the best jihad is to raise your
voice against a tyrant,
an oppressor.
Why? You see, if you read the for this,
the have explained if you go to a
physical jihad, if I go to a battle, and
we're not going to define, we're going
to define jihad is if there is a khalifa
and he puts a forward, that's the only
way we have a valid jihad.
We go to a jihad to fight in the cause
of Allah subhana wa ta'ala. There is a
5050% chance that I might live or I
might die.
Right? I might live. I might die.
But speaking up against the tyrant, you
are guaranteed to get hit. You are
guaranteed that you're going to get
prosecuted. You're going to get a
persecution.
Just all those folks who had their
visas revoked, who were dragged in
handcuffs, who were kidnapped in
daylights, that's what happens when you
speak against a tyrant.
That's a guarantee.
But you see, once again, we do a
fabulous job of compartmentalizing it.
Every Friday we are taught to read
because it acts as a light a shield for
us from one Friday to the next Friday.
Have we ever pondered why?
Why?
And if we pondered on it, have we
dissected it further than what it is
meant to be?
Unfortunately not.
Yes, there is a trial of faith in it.
There's a trial of money and the wealth.
Yes, there's a trial of knowledge. Yes,
there's a trial of power. Yes, but what
does that mean?
You see, let me focus on the trial of
knowledge.
The story behind it happens to be is
that
Matamat wasam one day is giving a sermon
and a man from Bani is stands up and
says yeah Mus who is the most
knowledgeable and Mus saysam I am and
there is no shock in it why he's aul he
has he has a Allah gave him theat so
he's the most knowledgeable amongst the
but the fact Allah did not his
arrogance.
He sends him on a quest to meet a person
who has
the wisdom.
MS has the knowledge. Why are we sending
Musa on a trip? Because he needs to
learn the wisdom,
right?
And what happens?
Can you teach me from the from the from
the wisdom you have been taught by
Allahh?
Ma, not your cup of tea, man. He won't
be able to do it.
Does MS know what he's signing up for?
Yes.
Does Musa know this guy has wisdom? Yes.
Because Allah sent him on a long
journey. So, he knows the story.
MS is not going blindsided in this into
this setup. He knows the story.
It's a trial for it's a test for MS
because if you read before that Mus goes
on a long journey with his with his
servant. So he goes he asks this guy
which isam and he says no man you will
not be able to hold your tongue. I know
you you won't survive this. And he says
I was look look inshallah I will be
patient. I will hold steady. I will hold
the rope and I will not disobey you in
any matter.
Now my words what the Quran is saying.
Okay.
What happens?
So they embark on a journey to learn
wisdom.
And the first first test happens when
they are in a in a small boat. They
cross the river. We get to the other
side and
decides that he's going to take a couple
of planks out. So the the boat is no
longer water worthy. It's sinking now.
It has water in it. What does MS do?
Does he stand by idly?
He's my teacher. I'm supposed to learn.
No, he speaks up.
He knows that he cannot hold his tongue
back because that's what
does to you.
You are the best nation that came
forward that you tell people of what is
good deed and what is a bad deed.
What is Msiah doing?
He's exercising his right to speak up.
He's saying, "Look, these people just
gave you a free ride across the river
and you helped you out. Didn't charge
you any money. No, you took the planks
out of the boat, bro. Not cool."
And what does he say to him? First thing
told you you're not going to be able to
tow the rope.
And Ma said, "Okay, okay, okay. You know
what? All right, deal. Let's make
another deal. I I I won't say anything
anymore."
Because this is what the humanity in you
demands.
You see a wrong, you call it a wrong.
That thing that inside you incites you
every night.
My table is full, but did my brothers
and sisters eat?
I have a shelter over my roof, but my
brothers and sisters have shelter.
I have running water in my house, but
that my people and my community have
running water. No,
this is what
asks from you.
What's the next story that we get into
Musa? I know the time is flying by, so
let me finish up real quick. What is the
next story? We get to MSA after he gets
out of the boat. What happens?
Finds a young boy, kills him
immediately. And MS is like, "What is
wrong with you? Why are you killing a
boy?" And he says, "Told you, Musa, you
won't be able to hold your tongue, man."
And he says, "Okay, okay." Because it's
wrong. He sees something happening and
he's speaking up constantly. How can
heul of Allah who was on Hak who was the
truth bearer how can he stand by idally
when things are going wrong
and then the last story comes up they
get to this town they ask the locals to
host them which is the tradition and the
sunnah is to host somebody in your town
for three days they're they are
considered a a a guest and they say you
know what no man we're not giving do
nothing. And finds a finds a a wall that
is about to fall over. Leaning over, he
goes and he fixes the wall and he's
done. And Musa has now completely lost
it. And he says, "Look, man, what are
you doing? They gave us no water. They
gave us no food. They gave us no
shelter. They told us to get away, run
out, shoe, and you're fixing their
walls." He says, "Ma, I told you again.
you won't be able to stop yourself.
You see the reason I'm mentioning this,
we read this story, but we do not see
the ethical response that's within the
story that's hidden there. The call
Allah is asking you to look and see.
Do not stand by idally
when there is oppression going on.
Do not stand by idally when things are
wrong.
Just because my stomach is full, I'm
secure, it doesn't mean that's okay.
You know, reminds me the
you know there's fna for every
for my
fa for my will be money.
Alhamdulillah we have accumulated a lot
of that. Alhamdulillah. Alhamdulillah.
may increase.
But what are we doing with it?
Nothing. We're doing nothing with it.
That's what the answer is. Because we're
not going to learn today. We're not
going to learn before. We didn't learn
in Spain. And we're not definitely not
learning today.
And that's the that's the reality of it.
I'll finish with
There is no there is no obedience there
is no bowing down to
if you are disobeying your Allah subhana
wa ta'ala that's it
if Allah subhanaa tala can bring you
halfway on the world to give you risk he
can take you another halfway around the
world to give you risk again his
his father.
We ask Allah subhana tala
to give us the insight and the knowledge
to read the Quran that is meant to be
read in way and act upon the haditham
the way he wanted us to act and to be
the community that he envisioned from
usatam.
First of all,
[Silence]
alhamdulillah.
The hadith wasallam mentions each one of
you is a shepherd and each one of you is
responsible for your flock meaning that
you will be answerable for what you have
done. As such,
over the last five years or so, I've
been that shepherd for this flock.
Regardless if you wanted me not to be or
if I wanted to be or not to be, I was
the shepherd. And as such, I hope to
Allahh that I have done my diligence and
due diligence of delivering his message
and the h to you all.
So I want to leave you with something
as we conclude our today.
You see most of us know that
the sea is salty.
It's salinated.
That water is not useful for drinking.
Neither it is useful to grow anything
with.
Meaning that if you were by the seaside
and you decided to use the water to feed
the plants, the plants would die unless
the water is processed.
But it has thriving life in it. There's
fish and other animals that live in it.
You would never find a fish that lives
in that salinated water
which tastes salty.
The fish doesn't have a taste.
I see some of you smiling cuz I think
you already got the punch line.
I see some of you confused. So, let me
repeat it one more time.
You see, the water in the sea is salty.
It is not beneficial for anything.
You and I cannot drink it. We cannot use
it to grow anything on land.
But there is life that thrives within
that water.
There's plants that thrive. There's sea
life that thrives.
But if you love if you have had the the
fish and the different things, they're
not salty
because they don't let their environment
clout who they are.
So if I was to teach you anything today
or if I leave you with anything that I I
think that you should go with forward
for rest of your life, it's that one
message. It's not your environment.
You're responsible for yourself.
You see, I I haven't seen it here, but
liies grow in in in ponds that have
dirty water, stagnant water. Lies are
very pure things. So be that person. Be
those entities. Be in the sea. Nobody's
denying you to not live in the sea. But
don't let that sea taint
who you are.
foreign.
[Silence]
All
Forham.
[Silence]
We ask Allah subhanaa tala to relieve
the sufference on our brothers and
sisters in first and foremost and Sudan
and in Congo and in China and in Burma
and in Kashmir. And we ask Allahh
wherever Muslims are suffering that he
brings aid to them and he puts mercy
upon them and he embraces their hearts
and he provides them food and shelter
and water from the avenues that we do
not exist and provide them with the
armies that we do not know they exist.
And we ask Allah subhana tala that he
keep our communities here safe and
sound. We ask Allahh to push all evil
away from our communities in the western
world. I want to take a moment and make
a dua for our brother who passed away in
if you're not aware the the the NYPD
officer who passed away in the mass
shooting in New York City, brother
as as along we make pray to Allah to
Allahh for all the brothers and sisters
who have passed away in the flooding in
Pakistan.
along with the floodings in the US, in
the West Virginia, in Texas and the
Carolinas. May Allah subhanaa tala have
mercy upon their souls. May Allah subh
provide sabar to their families. May
Allah subhana tala gather their affairs
for them and may Allah subhanaa tala
make an exit for them from all the
suffering they're continue to suffer.
May Allah subhana ta grant us ease all
of us in our affairs.
forbill.
[Silence]
Allahill.
Please stand in your lines. Fill the
gaps in between. Just make sure your
back of the foot is on the white line
behind you and your stuff will be
straight inshallah. Shoulder tosh
shoulder please.
If the chairs need to be removed, please
remove the chairs.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
for
Amen.
[Silence]
All
the
shore.
[Silence]
What the smell of beah?
Fore
[Silence]
speech.
Sah
like
[Silence]
love.
Alhamdulillah.
for
him.
Amen.
for
[Silence]
Fore
inch.
[Silence]
Allah
say Allah hid.
Allah love.
[Silence]
like
Brothers and sisters, asalam alalaykum.
I do want to have a conversation with
you brothers and sisters. So please bear
with me for a minute. I want to share
you with you some thoughts and I need
some help. first of all as you know
when we built this masjid our focus was
to f on the youth and the youth programs
and if you remember we made the first
place that we built was gymnasium
and then the place for you know the
musah and all that stuff was done later.
We wanted to really make sure over time
we have done a great job and now we have
musah is filled but our youth programs
are not as well progressing. So
understanding that we wanted to put a
re-emphasis on that piece. So with that
we are coming up with a a solution where
we take the spiritual religious
activities under one person that's going
to be our new Imam that has this
inshallah will be coming Monday. Imam
Ali
he's here. Okay he's here somewhere. If
he's either hearing me and if I'm wrong
he can tell me his spelling is correct
incorrect. Anyway, Imm Ali,
he is here and inshallah he'll be
leading that activity for the religious
activities for the youth program that we
have we find deficient in. We're going
to have Imam Hassan take that full
responsibility and go full speed. He
will not have a cap on whatever budget
he needs. We'll provide that inshallah.
We also give the opportunity for Imam
Hassan to give any in the local masjid
or anywhere he's invited. He is welcome
to go take that and expand our horizon
inshallah as in the community. We
already have some requests for his
hutbas and I just wanted to make sure
that alhamdulillah community in Tucson
and in Phoenix area is willing to
entertain our you know our the the
resources inshallah.
So this change will be effective Monday.
We will have inshallah full program by
Imam Ali that he is he's
you know just he's sharing with us that
he's going to have all he will be
present for all mostly all the prayers
in Tusan in in in the in in the week and
inshallah there will be a katra every
fudger after fudger and after isha. So
please start taking care you know at
least joining us. The hakas have to grow
from that perspective. The youth program
needs to encompass and we need to take
time to build a good program which
includes the the the the teams of kids
playing together whether it's basketball
or something else that we need to
arrange for the Saturday Sunday I mean
weekend school has to be expanded. So we
find some deficiencies that we're going
to correct inshallah needs your help to
make sure you are patient number one
number two if the you know participate
in those activities that we are
announcing that's the only way we will
know if those are effective or we need
to adjust so we are willing to take
anybody's input see me or brother Jabber
or Imam Ali or Imam Hassan and we'll
figure out a way to take satisfy your
needs inshallah
The Rahma Academy will be starting
officially on Tuesday inshallah
and the enrollment is opened and I want
to share with you something very
beautiful. Alhamdulillah here we have a
93 children enrolled that is a bigger
number that it was when there was a
full-blown building and a school on
river road called Alhuda. So,
alhamdulillah,
[Arabic recitation]
excitement on this one.